- We'll get some random words
and then I'll freestyle rap about them,
and you still seem very unconvinced.
(audience laughing)
People over here,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Your grandmother.
- My grandmother?
(audience laughing)
On my mother's side or my father's side?
One of them is alive so choose wisely.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Mother's side.
- Mother's side?
Correct, well done.
(audience laughing)
I mean, I haven't checked
the family WhatsApp
in the last hour, I don't know.
Also over there,
it's like two in the morning,
so she could have gone her sleep.
I hope not.
(audience laughing)
Fun fact, often I'll put my
freestyle raps on the internet
and I know my grandmother
subscribes to my YouTube channel
and watches all of them and
shows them to her friends.
So, hi grandma.(laughs)
I hope you've not gone in your sleep.
(audience laughing)
People over people over here,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member 2] Tootsie Rolls!
- Tootsie rolls?
In the UK, our candy is
very different to yours.
Is that, what type of candy is that?
- [Audience Member 2] Lord knows.
- Lord knows, it's an evangelical candy.
Strange.
(audience laughing)
Tootsie Rolls, the evangelical candy.
And let's come to the kind of middle,
people on like that side of the room,
like the back of the room,
what do you want a rap about?
- [Audience Member 3] Porn!
- Pardon?
- [Audience member 3] Porn.
- Porn, okay.
What particular type of pornography?
And let me say,
you don't have to give me a real one.
You could make up a
category all of your own,
and you can say you're being creative.
Actually, we'll all know that
your deepest, darkest fantasy.
(audience laughing)
So just get some
adjectives and some nouns,
smash them together,
that's the type of porn
we're rapping about.
- [Audience Member 3] Bukkake!
- No, that exists.
That's where lots of men do
a spunk on a lady's face.
(audience laughing)
No, I want to create one.
That's gonna be more fun.
It's Halloween,
let your evil minds run around.
- [Audience Member 4] Double penetration!
- Double penetration exists, come on!
You could have been fun.
You could have said
Hubble Bubble penetration.
That would have been better, right?
Let's let's come up with-
- [Audience Member 4]
(indistinct) penetration.
- No, no.
Don't do my work for me.
(audience laughing)
Come on. Let's let's get some-
- [Audience Member 5] Sexy panda porn!
- Sexy panda porn!
Thank you.
And wait, what did you say over there?
- [Audience Member 6] Jailhouse chicks!
- Jailhouse chicks, okay.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, sounds exploitative.
I mean, we should shut down Rikers, yes.
So my grandmother, Tootsie
rolls the evangelical candy,
either sexy Panda porn or jailhouse porn.
People over here,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member 7] A Wrinkle in Time!
- A Wrinkle in Time?
It's that book that was then,
was that the one that was
adapted and kind of sunk
without a trace?
- [Audience Member 7] Yeah.
- Yeah, okay. A Wrinkle in Time.
Never read it but we'll rap about it.
So my grandmother on my mother's side,
sexy panda porn or jail house chicks,
Tootsie rolls the evangelical candy,
and what was the one from over here?
- [Audience Member 7] A Wrinkle in-
- A Wrinkle in Time, of course, yeah.
No one else remembered that. (laughs)
They were just like, okay,
(audience laughing)
Well, we'll start with that one.
This is gonna be a freestyle
rap and my lovely band,
they're gonna drop a beat.
So let's hear what we're gonna do,
let's see what it's gonna be.
I'm excited.
You are so tickled by this,
my lady down here.
It's gonna be fun.
It's gonna be very fun and let's do this.
Nice, cool.
(band playing)
♪ Never read but construct
it, think in my mind ♪
♪ Let me read the sci-fi
book, A Wrinkle in Time ♪
♪ Probably aimed at the YA, young adult ♪
♪ I've not read it,
but it's not my fault ♪
♪ It never took off in
the UK, United Kingdom ♪
♪ If you got a local library,
you should really bring them ♪
♪ Some great books, act like a smoothie ♪
♪ The library in flight,
they made this a movie ♪
♪ Truly a fact, I never went to see it ♪
♪ Was Whoopi Goldberg in
the air, I think I recall ♪
♪ Seeing on a poster, her face maybe ♪
♪ I'm sure it had some
other great acting ladies ♪
♪ And some kids probably acting less ♪
♪ When I'm in the jail ♪
♪ You're allowed to see the breasts ♪
♪ I'm in the showers ♪
♪ Looking at the gals undress ♪
♪ I say oh, what's gonna happen next ♪
♪ One getting down on the
knees giving gals a lick ♪
♪ I be like subscribing,
clicks jailhouse chicks ♪
♪ That's what I really
like, a morning rub ♪
♪ I want my jailhouse
chicks on the Porn Hub ♪
♪ And that's JC, that's the acronym ♪
♪ Like Jesus Christ and
you know I'm adoring him ♪
♪ I'm like oh, to be as
good as you is my goal ♪
♪ Die for my sins, get a Tootsie Roll ♪
♪ Is what I'm asking ♪
♪ Yes I want to eat,
walking down the street ♪
♪ Like a little girl's trick or treat ♪
♪ Get into the house,
no Reese's in my mouth ♪
♪ 'Cause the Tootsie Roll
is what I'm truly about ♪
♪ How many licks does it
take to get to the center ♪
♪ Maybe like three or four ♪
♪ Yeah you know I meant to lie to you ♪
♪ I've actually ate one
once, it was horrible ♪
♪ I spat it out my mouth
from my bonce on the floor ♪
♪ I'm like I don't understand,
you're tasting candy ♪
♪ But I like the pandas ♪
♪ All over there, makes me erect ♪
♪ When I see a little black and
white bear looking so sexy ♪
♪ I don't want a brown one or a grizzly ♪
♪ I want the one from China getting busy ♪
♪ I see the little panda, gyrating ♪
♪ And then he stands there,
hesitating, he's waiting, why ♪
♪ Well obviously, you can deduce ♪
♪ Pandas really struggle to reproduce ♪
♪ They never get it off
when they're in captivity ♪
♪ Maybe get the jailhouse
panda proclivity ♪
♪ Put it on, they start subscribing ♪
♪ The panda sees it, he's
like oh I'm arriving ♪
♪ He's got a low voice, like
he comes from Yorkshire ♪
♪ It's where my grandmother's
from, yeah I talked to ♪
♪ Her directly, like
I'm outta the camera ♪
♪ I say hi there, I love
you grandma, you're cool ♪
♪ Even though you hips
break, your knees weak ♪
♪ I hope you're still alive,
please don't go in your sleep ♪
♪ If you did, everybody's panicking ♪
♪ They're like Chris with all the rhymes ♪
♪ You're managing to talk about this ♪
♪ Even though she might
be gone, no she's great ♪
♪ Let me take it back, World War I ♪
♪ She wasn't alive then,
that would be so mental ♪
♪ Back in the day, she didn't
have quinoa or lentil ♪
♪ She just ate flour,
she just ate potatoes ♪
♪ If she got a hole in her
socks, then she'd don those ♪
♪ Reuse yeah, in fact we say this ♪
♪ Obviously she's old, so
obviously she's racist ♪
♪ And that's fine,
before me she was born ♪
♪ If she saw this, she'd
be like Chris what's porn ♪
♪ I'd have to explain it,
she wouldn't understand ♪
♪ I'd say you sit down with
a laptop on your hand ♪
♪ She says which one, It doesn't
matter which hand's there ♪
♪ And what do you do,
click on jails or pandas ♪
♪ This one people getting into
each other's gashes there ♪
♪ This one's at the zoo,
they make a little baby ♪
♪ It's really cute, please ♪
♪ Best panda sexy porn's
the one where it sneezed ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
(audience applauding)